do you regret any aspect of just giving
everything to your vision
I mean you've spoken about that saying
like I got [ __ ] over in the business
side I promise that I had to stop
envying
cool people
at their current cool time
if anything if someone's cool
and I say their name a lot I'm gonna
Flash
the light on them so much that it ages
their coolness it's actually a war
technique
showered in compliments yeah you know
because that that you that to be able to
stay at 45 years old to still be the bad
kid in class at 45 I'm still in the
principal's office because if you look
at like say fashion right if you think
of something fashionable it's probably
gonna look like the kid in the
principal's office
that's going to be the fashion and
that's part of the reason why I'm the
most influential person and fashion and
fashion because I refuse to leave the
principal's office if the substitute
teacher comes in I'm gonna say you got a
big butt yeah I'm gonna get and they go
right back right back to the principal's
office and people gonna be like yo
and that's what you keep on saying like
who can we talk to
because no one can talk to me no I'm out
of control bro it's just God then me and
then [ __ ] everybody you know I mean
that's how that's really how I live my
life
and I would just want to say this one
thing about the children thing I wanted
to you know put that point together put
that idea together I don't like the word
point I'm really big on like Words Words
being powerful says the person with the
Sleepy tweet
um so you're full of contradictions yeah
I'm a human being right it's like some
days I'm like I could go 30 days to be
celibate you know like really like I'm a
monk I'm being like faithful to God and
then I'll go like working out no carbs
like my weight will fluctuate and I'll
have time so I'm like I don't feel like
being told what to do so I don't want to
work out with a trainer and I just want
to drink this Hennessy but I want to say
this thing that I will text to Kim
sometimes I'll say you know
you may not understand
what I'm doing right now but you will
and that's what I would say to everyone
you may not understand what I'm doing
and this gives a little bit maybe we're
like 20 there but there's still going to
be people we leave this interview and
they'll be like I still don't like the
way you apologize I still don't want to
say what my involvement would have been
to make him lead him to that point and
we just want things to be how they are
there's people in the world who want the
world to stay as it is and there's
people who want to change the world and
that's happened throughout time they say
that with da Vinci halfway into a
conversation he could not suffer fools
so much that he would walk away halfway
into the conversation and I said well
that's why
it's The DaVinci Code and not the da
Vinci world
and every time I go and piss off a group
of people or do these things on some end
it's like I could be turning my thing
from a potential World Vision to a code
or I could be opening up conversations
with new friends that I may trust
someday yeah that's beautiful that's
beautiful that that because the change
you will have on the world that you
don't know for sure but it'll happen
across
uh years even decades so you have to
think in the future like you're working
in the future your actions are working
in the future and a lot of people will
judge this conversation and others
you've done and so on in the present and
that doesn't matter you know why I
apologize when I say I'm sorry to the
Jewish people that I hurt
it's not about like I said oh I said I'm
not gonna hold this apology hostage
right it's obviously it's about God but
God is everything right so what's the
point of even having language and being
you can't engineer if he's a God God
right it's like it's God has us to be
judgmental so that you become if you're
a doctor right it's your judgment that
saves grandma right and God puts that in
this like we have God inside us we're a
peace of God also right so I'm gonna go
specific to a person
that story about Da Vinci alone
is enough of a reason for me to give a
sincere apology to the Jewish people
because I do believe that there's a da
Vinci Code inside of all of my
misspellings and scribbles right here
that God wants me to get to the world
and
when I'm in my way if God has set
something on me when I'm in my way I'm
in God's way now I can point at other
people and say hey you guys are in God's
way because you're not listening to me
but if I'm in my way I'm not listening
to God and for me to be a philosopher
and a leader whatever other language I
have to listen to God so before God what
I will do is start off as a samurai
and say I'm sorry for hurting you
as a Jewish person I'm sorry for the way
that made you feel and I'm sorry for the
entire
uh population of a race that I feel is
actually my brothers because I classify
and feel that I'm also connected with
Christ in that way that my people came
from Africa and that way and I can't say
it's this exact teaching or that exact
teaching but I feel that there's an
important you know the sons of Abraham
however we want to word it right for us
to come together and bring our different
talents together to serve God
collectively And he as much of an alien
as I am he does not cause me he did not
call for me to alienate and that's what
the problem has been especially in
politics and in America he plays America
as the TV as the radio to the World We
Invented rock and roll right we are the
influencers of the rest of the planet
we're the um we're the youngest startup
in history right we're the youngest
country where the we're the youngest
superpower right so for me in my
position the fact that I can talk to
Trump one day and be at a game with Kim
Kardashian the next day and then be at
Paris fashion week they don't want me to
be involved with language of decisive
divisive language you know proving that
I can be just as racist as a racist
white person oh I can I could be a
racist black person also that's not what
God has called me to do so how do I
simplify and say hey to you as a
Visionary as a as an engineer as a
person that's given me a platform that
as my brother I want to apologize to you
for how that made you feel and to the
rest of
the people that carry specifically that
pain not the pain that I talk about that
doesn't seem to be as much of a pain for
people when I talk about the abortion
clinics and stuff that's it's like
that's the argued pain even in my own
Community like not everyone thinks it's
a pain but for the Jewish Community it's
collectively this was a pain and I've
gone I've gone so far just
psychologically on this journey since
that statement had happened
where I didn't want to like give up the
candy in my pocket I didn't want to say
hey I stuck my can my hand in a candy
jar I wanted to defend my freedom of
speech I wanted this but even with
freedom of speech pain is pain causing
people to hurt is not helping causing
people to hurt is not helping so that
means I have to take a a more
sophisticated approach
to
engineering this problem this problem is
the opportunity
and yes
that what could some people may deem as
a mistake would it be more genuine if I
called it a mistake
I think I would be uh hypocritical by
calling a mistake with what the ending
that the idea I'm gonna say out loud so
I I'm not I don't try to be a hypocrite
on purpose uh so but I will call it a
mistake to add a genuine uh to be
genuine
about the feeling
with that mistake
with me as a human being
not to justify but I have to state that
God makes no mistakes because if I
hadn't made that mistake I wouldn't be
in front of you today and that's not to
justify
this
uh uh sleepy text but I can tell you're
a man that has love in his heart and I
hear that I hear it through the words
explicitly and implicitly and I I think
if we're to engineer a better future the
way to do that is with love
so as one human to another
I love you brother thank you for talking
today this is great
I like you too son of a [ __ ]